der elende brh exit meine damen und
herren endlich in der zielgruppe gibt es
auf den letzten metern noch ein deal
oder nicht liegt also die vernunft oder
der nackte wahnsinn
beide vernunft und nackter wahnsinn
haben sich am mittwoch in brüssel
getroffen in gestalt von ursula von der
leyen und boris johnson drei stunden
haben sie da diskutiert es gab
jakobsmuscheln und steinbutt und zum
nachtisch kein ergebnis
bis sonntag wollen die briten angeblich
entscheiden ob sie wirklich ökonomischen
selbstmord begehen was mir aufgefallen
ist bei diesem treffen da die uschi ist
ganz schön dominant
da müssen natürlich oft die ursache hat
sieben kinder
da kann sich so ein
verhaltensauffälliger premier auch nicht
mehr schocken
es ist ja klar no deal wäre für beide
seiten blamabel nach vier jahren
gesprächen beziehungsweise sich
thematisch im kreis drehen im club eu
gibt man einen teil seiner souveränität
ab und genießt dafür binnenmarkt und
zollfreiheit fertig und hat mit rund 500
millionen bürgern natürlich ein ganz
anderes standing gegenüber super mächten
wie china england alleine viel spaß
die kette der eu kann nur so stark sein
wie ihr schwächstes glied und das
britische glied ist gemacht aus
marshmallows merkwürdige metapher aber
ich ahne was er meint boris johnson
zieht sein marshmallow ding eisern durch
weil er viel mehr angst vor seiner
partei hat als vor dem modellwechsel ja
es ist wirklich so großbritannien
wickelt rund die hälfte der im und
exporte mit der eu ab beinahe befürchten
experten mindestens endlose lkw staus
vielleicht sogar leere supermarktregale
dann droht england die schlimmste
rezession seit 300 jahren sagt man
mitten in der pandemie die ja auch
katastrophal manager so irgendwann
reicht's auch mal
sie sahen einen ausschnitt aus der
vierten staffel der frauen endlich mal
realistisch tatsächlich bleiben nur noch
tage für eine einigung ab erster januar
kamen unweigerlich zelle
auch in deutschland werden
hunderttausende arbeitsplätze in gefahr
und alles nur weil diese drag city ihren
fans jahrelang versprochen haben wenn
wir erst mal raus sind aus der eu
dann wird toni brillant inzwischen
formuliert der eine oder die andere
schon etwas vorsichtiger niemand hat
eine garantie dafür ausgesprochen dass
es durch den brand nicht zu
veränderungen kommt menschen könnten
ihre jobs verlieren aber das könnten
sich auch neue chancen ergeben könnte
doch sein oder wir finden öl oder gewinn
im lotto weiß doch keiner
und selbst wenn es noch ein last minute
ihr gibt in den nächsten stunden wer
garantiert dass sich boris johnson dann
auch daran hält darf man nie vergessen
der mann hat sein ganzes leben quasi
durch gelogen ist alles wirklich nur
noch schade richtig schade so ein tolles
land kluge kreative menschen sagt nur
monty python die beatles oliver twist
[Musik]
warum raus aus der eu
warum
raus aus der eu weil wir auf die lügen
von buch ist schätzt reingefallen sind
deshalb steht trotz nase traurig vor
allem zwei große streitpunkte gibt es
fairer wettbewerb und fischerei fische
warum nur 0,1 prozent des britischen
bruttoinlandsprodukts werden aus dem
meer gezogen
bitter wird er für die franzosen wenn
die keine britischen gewässern fischen
dürfen auch deutsche kutter wären
betroffen
wir schalten mal leicht zu matthias
matschke die rings fischer in fünfter
generation der matschke
wie steht's denn im fish creek bloß auf
tue ich bin so lange dabei ich habe
unter captain sind kluge lehrern aber
was für abwehr alle bekloppt mensch sagt
man verschiedene nationalitäten oder
makrele ist das doch piep schnurz egal
ob die engländer ja es gibt ja
hoheitsgewässer so jetzt aber auch durch
schiebt so ein junger hering
er wird für irland geboren frist ich da
auf eu-kosten fett und schwimmt dann zu
den engländern
deswegen gehört der den glauben macht
yoga wir können ja unter wasser so
schilder aufstellen damit die angeblich
zwischen sieger zu uns zurück finden
rocker ja weil man die britischen
kollegen über funk anspricht um sich
abzustimmen
wo genau man fährt wo die netze sind
dann rufen die nur rexit engländer
überlegt mal wer euren fischkauf über
zweiter hilfe von dem was sie wollen
verkaufen wir ihnen die eu da muss doch
mal so langsam der groschen fallen oder
in die fischer von wales haben sich
jetzt eines besseren besonnen sie wohl
nicht mehr aus dem binnenmeer das
plötzlich eingefallen wenn sie nicht im
binnenmarkt denn da müssen sie ihn
selber
essen ja und zwar zum frühstück zu mit
wir sitzen doch am längeren hebel
die sollte ich mal wachsen lassen unsere
brüsseler boxen
wenn wir nicht mehr verändern fischen
dürfen wir als unsere eigenen sachen
kommen wieder ohne ende
lecker wurst von tönnies oder es oder
man regelt das wie erwachsene und einigt
sich auf vernünftige fangquoten und er
hat vielleicht auch mal auf die bestände
so zu überfischen das ist doch unser
eigentliches problem mir was von frank
wurden wir haben nur ein problem die
englischen kollegen dahin durch die
londoner und ganz aber es wäre womöglich
ein wirtschaftliches desaster
das glaube ich nicht ich wüsste nicht
warum wenn wir die besten produkte in
der welt produzieren
dann werden diese auch andere länder
weiter mit schuss los das ist deutsch im
akw ist ein ski matthias matschke
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
nike dallas ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da